Я проживаю в місті потивель Сумської
області та я засновниця молодіжної
громадської організації час обрав
нас познайомилася з цим етносом в 7
років коли почала займатися вокалом
оскільки співали ми саме автентичні
пісні горюнів і згодом вже коли
відкривали громадську організацію першою
ідеєю для проєкту були горюни
популяризація їх в
масси з січня ми запускаємо річний
проект це курс по грантрайтингу
фандрейзингу краундфайдингу та
проектному менеджменту він розрахований
на 1500 осіб з 51 громади Сумської
області покоління Перемоги - це молодь
яка є розшійною силою яка жадає Перемоги
та робить все можливе для цього тому я
дуже рада що мене оточує саме така
молодь такі
однолітки